[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est sens public votre rendez-vous
quotidien de débat et de reportage sur
public c'est la 90 minutes pour donner
du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
experts et voici le sommaire de ce 5
avril Donald Trump inculpé par un
procureur de New York et si c'était une
aubaine pour l'ancien président
américain
nos élections ressemblaient à celles
d'un pays du tiers-monde et maintenant
c'est ingérence électorale massive à une
échelle jamais vue dans notre pays en
commençant par la gauche radicale le
procureur Alvin braque de New York
soutenu par George Soros
cette procédure place de nouveau Trump
au centre du jeu médiatique elle oblige
c'est concurrents à la primaire
républicaine a le soutenir on va
décortiquer les conséquences de cette
inculpation et les autres affaires plus
graves qui menacent le milliardaire et
puis pour notre débat de société
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour c'est le thème des violences
conjugales que je vous propose ce soir
il y a un mois la première ministre a
annoncé la création de 200 pôles
spécialisés au sein des tribunaux est-ce
la bonne solution que faire pour mieux
protéger les victimes quel bilan
pourrait Emmanuel Macron en six années
de pouvoir ne ratez pas notre second
débat dans trois quarts d'heure mais
d'abord donc l'histoire du jour qui nous
emmène aux États-Unis quand un
ex-président est rattrapé par la justice
de son pays pour avoir tenté d'étouffer
trois affaires c'était avant l'élection
de 2016 redam Rabbit
un salut discret assez supporters la
mine est grave en entrant dans le
tribunal pénal de Manhattan Donald Trump
est en état d'arrestation du jamais vu
pour un ancien président des États-Unis
il révisé par 34 chefs d'accusation
notamment pour avoir acheté de silence
de plusieurs personnalités dont une star
du porno en marge de la présidentielle
de 2016 quelques clichés subsistent de
cette première audition face au juge
Trump pleine non coupable
[Musique]
dans l'État de New York qui que vous
soyez nous ne pouvons pas normaliser et
nous ne banalisons pas les combines
délictuelles graves
pendant ce temps-là devant le tribunal
c'est la Cohu partisan pro et anti Trump
s'investit
de l'audience Donald Trump se rendent
ensuite dans son fief de mars à Lago en
Floride attendu par des milliers de
partisans il réfutent toutes les
accusations
je n'aurais jamais imaginé cela possible
en Amérique je n'aurais jamais imaginé
que cela puisse arriver le seul délic
que j'ai commis c'est d'avoir défendu
sans Peur notre pays face à ceux qui
cherchent à le détruire
l'ancien président américain se dit
victime d'une cabale poétique son procès
devrait débuter au début de l'année 2024
on débat autour des conséquences
politiques de cette inculpation avec
André caspy bonsoir bienvenue au 12
accueillir vous êtes professeur et
mérita la Sorbonne et vous publiez mais
chronique américaine livre édité aux
éditions de l'Observatoire ils achètent
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'Université Paris Nanterre et l'actrice
en chef de la revue politique américaine
Idris bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
professeur de droit public et
spécialiste des États-Unis et puis on
était également duplex avec Olivier
python avocat en droit public américain
et bonsoir auteur de Kamal Harris la
pionnière de l'Amérique publié chez
plomb et Mathieu croissanto bonsoir
Mathieu éditoris politique que risque
Donald Trump André caspi après cette
inculpation
il risque de passer en jugement si du
moins il est reconnu coupable pour
l'instant ça n'est pas encore le cas il
est au stade de l'instruction et bien
entendu cela veut dire que il peut être
soumis à la justice si les
accusations qui sont portées contre lui
sont fondées on disait dans le sujet
procès possible en janvier il y a quand
même pas mal d'inconnus oui alors
janvier
2024 ça voudrait dire que c'est le début
de l'année électorale ça veut dire aussi
que en novembre 2024 il y aura des
élections présidentielles et dès le mois
de janvier de toute évidence la bataille
commencera elle a déjà d'ailleurs
commencé mais enfin elle s'intensifiera
dans la carrière d'homme d'affaires de
Donald Trump est-ce qu'il a souvent eu
affaire au tribunaux est-ce que
finalement même si c'est une on l'a dit
une première dans l'histoire américaine
est-ce que c'est un habitué des
tribunaux Donald Trump alors il l'a eu
oui plusieurs démêlés avec les tribunaux
qui on peut remonter dans les années
70-80 mais regardons déjà ce qui se
passe maintenant c'est à dire qu'il a
d'autres procédures en cours qui sont
beaucoup plus graves que cette affaire
stormy Danielle les élections truquées
en Géorgie son rôle dans l'invasion du
Capitole ou encore la détention de
documents classifiés donc il a de
nombreuses affaires en cours c'est
peut-être la première de d'autres
journées qui ressemblerait à celle-ci
est-ce qu'on peut se dire ça
en tout cas celle-ci est
particulièrement médiatisée elle est
sulfureuse elle implique une actrice de
films X donc ça fait particulièrement
jaser alors qu'il y a d'autres il y a
d'autres cas dans ce dossier qui a été
mis au jour par le procureur brag
puisqu'on parle aussi d'une autre
maîtresse qui avait été achetée même
d'un concierge qui a été acheté donc il
y avait en fait une toute une cellule de
démantèlement des nouvelles désagréables
au sujet de Donald Trump qui avait été
monté et c'est ça dont il est question
dans la fin de New Yorkaise Idriss
pourquoi cette procédure à la boutique
maintenant le fait qu'il date de 2016
effectivement c'est intéressant c'est
que elle avait été entamé par l'ancien
procureur qui avait déjà tenté
effectivement de lancer une mise en
examen et qui avait renoncé face à la
complexité de la procédure et le
procureur en question le nouveau
procureur élu en 2021 avait au départ
était très réticent parce que
précisément la mise en examen repose sur
une construction juridique assez
complexe puisqu'il y a deux éléments qui
sont reprochent à Donald Trump le
premier c'est d'avoir fait des faux
documents une fausse déclaration une
fois c'est écriture comptable
en présentant comme étant des frais
d'avocat ce qui était le remboursement
de l'avocat et pour qu'il s'agisse d'un
crime et non pas d'un délit il faut que
ce faux cette fausse déclaration soit
liée à un crime et c'est là qu'on a dans
la difficulté juridique parce que le
procureur a estimé que le deuxième crime
en question était soit une infraction à
la législation en matière de campagne
électorale soit une infraction à la
matière fiscale à la législation fiscale
et c'est là où c'est très compliqué
parce qu'on est dans une construction
assez audacieuse et Donald Trump ses
avocats pourront dire effectivement on
me traite de manière particulière
justement de manière anormale ce qui est
la preuve de la politisation de
l'instrumentalisation du système
judiciaire ça on y reviendra évidemment
je vous propose d'entendre l'extinction
on a eu un cours extrait dans dans le
reportage de Reda tout à l'heure
la déclaration justement du procureur
Alvin brag il parle de plus de 30
fausses déclarations de l'ancien
président
en début d'après-midi Donald Trump a été
mis en accusation par la Cour suprême de
l'État de New York sur la base d'un acte
d'accusation établi par un grand jury de
Manhattan pour 34 chefs d'accusation il
est accusé de falsification de document
commerciaux au premier degré en vertu de
la législation de l'État de New York la
fac signification de documents
commerciaux dans l'intention de
commettre une fraude et de dissimuler un
autre devis constitue un débit c'est
exactement ce dont il s'agit dans cette
affaire 34 fausses déclarations faites
pour dissimuré d'autres déris il s'agit
de dégrade dans l'État de New York qui
que vous soyez nous ne pouvons pas
normaliser et nous ne banaliserons pas
les conduites d'éluelles graves je
reviens vers vous
Idriss face à si est-ce que ce que
j'entendais un peu dans la décla est-ce
que le dossier est assez solide parce
que c'est un ancien président américain
donc c'est toute la question et
finalement c'est le dilemme qui pose au
système judiciaire parce que d'un côté
il y a la logique de l'État de droit qui
pour que tout le monde soit à fait la
même manière donc personne y compris un
ancien président est au dessus des lois
mais de l'autre il y a un constat
réaliste pragmatique qui est de dire que
un ancien président n'est pas un citoyen
ordinaire autrement dit pour pouvoir
mettre en examen un ancien président il
faut que l'accusation soit
particulièrement solide et c'est là au
regard de ce qui a été déclaré hier on
peut avoir effectivement des doutes et
peut-être que d'autres affaires
effectivement l'affaire du Capitole
était peut-être un véhicule avec un
vecteur plus solide pour mettre en
examen Donald Trump Olivier python votre
avis d'avocat je rappelle en droit
public américain sur la solidité de de
l'accusation contre Donald Trump sur
cette première affaire à celle dont on
parle aujourd'hui
oui non mais ce qui a été dit est tout à
fait juste si vous voulez il y a deux
chapitres le premier chapitre c'est le
chapitre des falsifications des
registres commerciaux comme on dit en
vertu de l'article 175 du code de l'État
de New York et c'est là-dessus que le
procureur Alvin braque s'est appuyé
effectivement pour inculper Donald Trump
et là-dessus incontestablement
d'ailleurs on l'a vu au moment de sa
présentation il avait l'air assez solide
et il pense pouvoir démontrer assez
facilement qu'il y avait effectivement
une volonté de falsification de
dissimulation des informations dites
commerciales le problème et ça a été dit
fort justement c'est que on parle bien
de de dissimulation de falsification
dans le but de commettre un crime et
là-dessus c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
c'est beaucoup plus fragile parce que le
crime ce serait quoi et Brague le dit
lui-même il parle en fait de
modification au bout du compte de
changement de de la perception de la de
l'élection 2016 là en revanche le lien
est infiniment plus ténu et c'est
beaucoup plus fragile et donc elle a
émis je dirais que ça n'est même pas
parce que le président les États-Unis
l'ex président des États-Unis n'est pas
un judiciable comme les autres le
problème c'est le lien de causalité
démontrer effectivement une
falsification des registres commerciaux
qui sont punis de 1 à 4 ans de prison au
maximum et le fait de déclarer de
manière implicite qu'en fait on aurait
au bout du compte changer la donne quand
à l'élection 2016 c'est un pas
extrêmement important extrêmement
compliqué à pouvoir à pouvoir démontrer
et c'est là dessus que ça puis la
défense de Donald Trump et en
particulier de son avocat vedette Joe
capochina qui est vraiment le le le
meneur là-dessus de la de l'offensive
face à Alvin brag et on va voir ce que
ça donne premier point oui deuxième
point beaucoup plus fragile mais je
termine là-dessus une phrase ce qui est
le plus important parce qu'on a rappelé
les autres affaires en particulier au
niveau fédéral qui qui inquiète Donald
Trump c'est une brèche un
contestablement il est inculpé on est
dans une brèche et peut-être que
d'autres vont s'engouffrer dedans
effectivement alors vous vous le dites
les uns et les autres ça offre aussi à
Donald Trump la possibilité d'attaquer
ou de contre-attaquer en écoutant un
extrait de la déclaration du de l'ancien
président américain
et voilà où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
j'ai un juge qui déteste Trump avec une
femme et une famille qui déteste Trump
dont la fille a travaillé pour Kamala
Harris et qui reçoit maintenant de
l'argent de la campagne bydenaris et
beaucoup d'argent
Olivier python je reviens vers vous
peut-être d'un mot rapide c'est de quoi
parle Donald Trump c'est un mensonge de
plus ou alors il y a vraiment des liens
entre la famille du procureur brag et et
la vice-présidente américaine le système
judiciaire américain est fondé sur
l'élection les juges sont élus et donc
si vous voulez ils sont élus donc ils
sont politisés et Donald Trump joue
là-dessus effectivement drague est un
démocrate si ta démocrates revendiqué
d'ailleurs Juan Merchan qui est le juge
qu'il avait déjà inquiété sur les
malversations de la tempe organisation
est également un démocrate donc il joue
il polititise évidemment le dossier et
cette bonne guerre effectivement le
problème c'est qu'on a une
interpellation un je veux dire une des
interférences entre l'aspect judiciaire
et l'aspect politique c'est
incontestable André caspi ça c'est tout
c'est comme ça la justice américaine est
comme ça
Donald Trump a eu en partie raison de
d'attaquer le procureur sur je crois que
l'affaire dépasse largement le domaine
judiciaire il s'agit d'une affaire
politique dans cette dans ce cas et
lorsqu'on cite les autres affaires qui
pourraient menacer Donald Trump il faut
quand même prendre ses distances parce
que par exemple sur ce qui s'est passé
le 6 janvier 2021 il y a eu une enquête
du Congrès Donald Trump si vous vous
rappelez bien auparavant a été par deux
fois jugé dans le cas d'un épica et par
deux fois il a échappé à toute
condamnation en ce qui concerne la
Géorgie dont on parle souvent rien n'est
fait pour le moment c'est-à-dire que en
effet il a vraisemblablement essayé de
faire pression sur les autorités de la
Géorgie pour qu'il change le résultat
des élections présidentielles mais
encore une fois ça n'a pas donné lieu à
une action judiciaire et puis
ça veut dire au fond que tout est fait
pour attaquer Donald Trump et en
attaquant Donald Trump on en fait une
victime et une victime qui en profite
bien entendu on voit bien par exemple
que en ce qui concerne l'opinion
publique le fait même d'être traduit
devant ta Juge augmente ses chances
auprès des électeurs notamment des
électeurs républicains donc ça veut dire
que le problème c'est de savoir si sur
le plan politique cela nuit à Donald
Trump ou est-ce que cela l'avantage moi
j'irai jusqu'à penser que cela
l'avantage c'est à dire qu'au fond
aujourd'hui il est plus fort du point de
vue électoral qu'il ne l'était il y a
une semaine deux semaines ou deux mois
donc ça veut dire qu'au fond là on est
entré dans la bataille des élections
présidentielles on y reviendra un peu
plus tard évidemment en longueur dans
Eva Mathieu où il est intervenir
sur le fond de l'histoire ce qu'on lui
reproche en fait d'avoir payé d'avoir
acheté le silence notamment de cette
fameuse actrice pornographique et on le
reproche voilà il y en a il y en a une
autre et puis avec l'argent de sa
campagne non en fait ce qu'on lui
reproche c'est d'abord orchestré une un
système pour effectivement pouvoir
éteindre ces histoires en fait système
en deux temps c'est son avocat personnel
Michael Cohen qui a payé effectivement
la crise en question et lui la remboursé
par la suite en prétendant qu'il
s'agissait des honoraires d'avocat or
c'était faux les remboursements qui lui
effectuaient et visaient simplement à le
rembourser du paiement qu'il avait fait
et c'est là où il y avait
plus le faire mais c'était risqué
politiquement c'était justement l'idée
c'est de mettre des tampons pour pas
pouvoir remonter directement à lui et
c'est là où le problème c'est que la
falsification c'est de présenter comme
les honoraires d'avocats un paiement qui
est fait à son avocat pour rembourser et
le lien avec le deuxième crime c'est de
dire il a voulu sens là contourner la
législation électorale puisque la
législation impose de déclarer toutes
les dépenses électorales et on peut dire
que supprimer une affaire constitue une
dépense électorale il faut quand même
reconnaître que 130 000 dollars par
rapport aux dépenses immenses d'une
campagne électorale c'est minuscule
c'est une miette une de Donald Trump
évidemment c'est trois fois rien mais à
la limite d'un point de vue juridique ça
demande pas en considération la question
peu importe le montant la question c'est
est-ce que vous avez respecté la
législation électorale que ce soit pour
10000 dollars ou un million la question
est fait calendrier qui est très clair
cette aventure avec stormy Daniel
c'était en 2006 or les les paiements qui
ont été faits ont été fait en 2016 donc
il ne pouvait pas se permettre de faire
ses paiements déjà un directement et
deux en pleine campagne électorale
d'ailleurs le dossier qui a été publié
indique bien qu'il aurait voulu
rembourser après la campagne mais
l'actrice faisait pression pour avoir
l'argent avant et il a dû la payer avant
la fin de la procédure sur son
supposés cette Storm et c'est à dire au
fond elle aime la tempête elle aime le
bruit elle aime de faire scandale et en
faisant scandale elle augmente
automatiquement les sommes qu'elle est
censée recevoir
il y a deux il y a deux questions qu'on
peut se poser aujourd'hui sur la
question d'une éventualité de voir
Donald Trump en prison ou de son
inéligibilité sont deux choses qui sont
pas forcément liées
laquelle des procédures dont on parle
pourrait éventuellement l'envoyer en
prison c'est très difficile à dire parce
qu'il y a pas de précédent moi je
voudrais vraiment insister sur le la
nécessité et plus que le désir la
nécessité de Donald Trump de scandaliser
cette affaire il a besoin d'argent ces
procédures lui coûtent extrêmement cher
et il a aussi une campagne à financer à
venir donc il a certes une fortune
personnelle importante estimée à 2,5
milliards de dollars mais le coût de sa
précédente campagne tout compris c'était
6, 5 milliards de dollars donc s'il veut
s'engager dans la campagne des primaires
et éventuellement dans la campagne des
présidentielles par la suite il a besoin
de mobiliser ses troupes puisque il est
déjà en train d'envoyer des mails à tout
va assez supporters pour que il y ait
des dons qui soient fait l'équipe de
Trump revendique 5 millions de dollars
levés depuis le début de cette mise en
examen donc il est vraiment très très
actif sur sur ce front alors on va y
revenir tout de suite sur cette question
de des levées de fonds grâce à Jonathan
du président et puis je vous reposerai
la question sur les questions prison
inéligibilité parce que je trouve ça
quand même intéressant salut on attend
bienvenue Bienvenue à vous donc on a
commencé à répondre à la question on se
dit à Donald Trump dans la tourmente
mais est-ce qu'il l'est vraiment et
est-ce que finalement ça peut pas être
un marche-pied pour sa future campagne
bah c'est ça on peut se demander si
c'est pas un peu à double tranchant
finalement ce qui est en train de lui
arriver ce qui va ce qui va pas se
traîner finalement ce fardeau judiciaire
jusqu'à sa course à la Maison Blanche ou
alors de l'autre côté se demander si ce
cirque médiatique qu'on auquel on
assiste depuis deux jours pourraient pas
être ce fameux tremplin pour justement
le ramener une nouvelle fois à la Maison
Blanche alors en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que l'annonce de son inculpation a
regonflé à bloc ses partisans qui
espèrent toujours et ben un grand retour
une restauration si on peut dire et puis
aussi pourquoi pas peut-être une
revanche sur Joe Biden écoutez-les
on soutient cet homme on aime le
président Trump c'est lui le vrai
président pas l'autre Sacko de Biden qui
a volé la dernière élection Silva en
prison pour une accusation aussi absurde
s'en est fini notre pays emballé c'est
peser comme en Union soviétique et pour
nous c'est terminé on existera plus
comme toujours Trump c'est un as un pro
dans le maniement des images oui et là
encore il a imposé ces conditions Donald
Trump un pas d'image filmé à l'intérieur
du tribunal de Manhattan seulement 5
photographes à être autorisées à entrer
avant que l'audience ne commence et pour
tout le reste et ben Trump a saturé
l'espace médiatique depuis deux jours
son avion qui décolle de la Floride vers
New York les convois de SUV noir dans
toutes les villes du pays sa sortie du
tribunal le salut à ses partisans le
point levé toutes ces images en fait on
servait à bâtir finalement un récit à
destination du monde entier celui d'un
homme qui est seul contre tous accablé
par une justice que lui pense aux ordres
des démocrates le sous-tex et ben c'est
Trump tel un phénix et ben pourquoi pas
pourrait renaître de ses cendres et il
est aussi très fort Donald Trump dans
cet exercice victimaire toujours se
positionner en victime finalement pour
ensuite ce comment dire faire je sais
même pas grand-chose
sur son agenda et donc on l'évoquait
avec Elisa shell au-delà de l'image ça
peut lui rapporter beaucoup et ouais de
l'argent Thomas beaucoup d'argent et
vous en parliez à l'instant il a besoin
d'argent pour financer sa campagne et là
en seulement 24 heures les dons ont
afflué de manière assez vertigineuse
Trump il a il aurait récolté 4 millions
de dollars rien qu'avec l'annonce de son
incubation ce qui est quand même assez
colossal et d'ailleurs son équipe de
campagne elle manque pas de d'insister
sur le fait que ça représente un
engouement finalement derrière le
candidat et qui qui pourrait d'ailleurs
tuer le match des primaires
républicaines à venir regarder ce
communiqué de l'équipe Trump qui va
s'afficher plus de 25% des dons
proviennent de nouveaux donateurs de la
campagne Trump ce qui renforce encore le
statut du président Trump en tant que
leader incontesté de la primaire
républicaine peut-on lire sur ce
communiqué et son équipe de campagne
elle s'arrête pas là elle va encore plus
loin pour lever des fonds vous allez
aussi le voir s'afficher sur votre écran
il y a des T-Shirts qui écoutent 36
dollars pièces et qui ont été mis en
vente avec l'inscription de notre guilty
non coupable en français avec un fac
similé du fameux portrait judiciaire ce
qu'on appelle aux Etats-Unis le mugshot
et en fait le mugshot et ben on voit là
que c'est une mise en scène de l'équipe
Trump le mugshot n'a pas été fait hier
effectivement merci à Jonathan on peut
revenir là-dessus tiens iris fassasiya
il a échappé à la photo d'identité
judiciaire c'est ça le privilège et
l'ancien président généralement
également les personnes sont menottées
effectivement ça n'a pas été le cas et
on s'en souvient
exactement la même chose devant Cyrus
Benz et là c'est effectivement des
égards pour pour l'ancien Président je
voulais revenir sur la question de
l'inéligibilité et faire le lien avec
les autres affaires parce que c'est un
point qui me semble important
effectivement en tant que enfin la
Constitution ne prévoit rien s'agissant
du casier judiciaire d'un candidat c'est
à dire que on peut très bien imaginer
que un candidat qui était condamné
puisse être élu président ça a été le
cas candidat en 1920 était même en
prison au moment de l'élection
présidentielle il obtenait 3%. il a fait
sa campagne président
et la tenue 3%. maintenant il y a une
disposition de la constitution du 14e
amendement qui prévoit que un individu
qui se rendrait coupable d'insurrection
ou de rébellion mesurer inéligible et
c'est là où c'est intéressant de faire
le lien avec l'enquête sur qui s'est
passé le 6 janvier c'est que précisément
la commission d'enquête parlementaire
elle a reconnu à pousser pour mettre en
avant l'insurrection et la rébellion et
maintenant le procureur spécial qui a
été nommé au niveau fédéral en cas sur
ce point et donc si il était condamné
sur ce point on pourrait envisager
inéligibilité mais d'un point de vue
réaliste la question c'est le calendrier
et il est fort probable que l'enquête ce
fameux soit pas bouclée avant 2020 alors
justement j'allais poser la question à
Olivier Pitot elle en est où cette
procédure liée à l'attaque du Capitole
on souvient les partisans de Trump
chauffait à blanc par les discours de
celui qui était encore président pour
quelques heures
oui d'abord rappeler le charme un charme
particulier de la de la de la démocratie
américaine c'est que si vous êtes en
prison vous êtes détenus vous avez le
droit d'être non seulement candidat mais
également élu président des États-Unis
en revanche vous n'avez pas le droit de
vote sauf dans deux états le main et le
Vermont donc c'est c'est tout le charme
de la de la de la démocratie américaine
comme le disait comme disait
effectivement mon confrère
deuxièmement alors il y a effectivement
sur les dossiers qui concernent une
possible condamnation pour insurrection
rébellion et là on est encore une fois
dans le cadre des affaires dites
fédérales c'est-à-dire le 6 janvier les
documents classifiés à Mara Largo et la
pression sur le secrétaire d'État de
Géorgie visant à obtenir quelques
milliers de lois supplémentaires pour
faire basculer l'État
là en revanche on est un peu dans le
flou artistique aucun des juges n'a pour
l'instant pris la décision de convoquer
Donald Trump en vue de son acuation dans
le cas du 6 janvier la commission
d'enquête qui s'est qui s'est fait qui
s'est réuni et qui a livré ses
conclusions juste avant le
renouvellement de la Chambre des
représentants qui redevenu républicaine
a estimé qu'effectivement il y avait une
responsabilité de Donald Trump mais
c'est au juge maintenant de se saisir de
ce dossier la
comment dirais-je la commission
d'enquête et parlementaire n'avait pas
la possibilité d'inculper évidemment
Donald Trump c'est un juge qui doit le
faire nous n'avons pas d'information
là-dessus sur un marlargo et les
documents classifiés nous attendons
également que le juge se décide et de
même pour la Géorgie encore une fois
même s'il y avait un culpassion dans les
semaines ou les mois qui viennent le
délai de la justice étant tellement long
les possibilités d'appel d'interjeter
appel serait tellement diverses qu'il
n'y a pratiquement aucune chance que
Donald Trump soit empêché de se
présenter à primaire voire même de se
présenter si l'autre gagner la primaire
républicaine de se présenter au mois de
novembre 2024 on est sur du temps long
et en tout cas sur l'affaire qui nous
concerne aujourd'hui là clairement non
même une incarcération ce qui est encore
une fois et tout à fait 13 improbable de
toute façon de mènerait pas son
inéligibilité ou à son incapacité à
pouvoir se faire élire comme président
André kaspille a victimisation c'est une
arme que Jonathan nous disait sur le
côté seul contre tous c'est une arme qui
l'a beaucoup utilisé
tout son intérêt c'est de montrer que on
lui en veut et on lui en dresse devant
lui toute une série d'obstacles et
d'obstacles qui ne permettent pas à la
souveraineté populaire de s'exprimer
c'est-à-dire Donald Trump apparaît comme
la victime de ses adversaires que Joe
Biden le président Joe Biden lui se
garde bien d'intervenir parce que au
fond il n'a qu'à laisser faire mais
est-ce que s'achemine vers une revanche
Trump contre byden aux élections
présidentielles de novembre 2024 je
pense que beaucoup d'Américains ne le
souhaitent pas parce que vraiment nous
avons eu en 2020 la bataille des
septuagénaires là nous aurions la
bataille des octogénaires et pour la
société américaine ça n'est pas très
glorieux donc ce que je crois c'est que
beaucoup d'Américains attendent que
Donald Trump soit lavé de ses soupçons
ou de ses accusations et qu'en revanche
il y est un nouveau candidat républicain
qui pourrait être le gouverneur de la
Floride Rhône De Santis revenir au fond
de l'affaire vous allez croire que je
fais une obsession non non mais c'est
bien comment dans un pays qu'on connaît
capable d'un excès de puritanisme en
particulier dans l'électorat républicain
comment les phrases que sexuelles de
Donald Trump glisse sur lui et les
achètent
une représentation de la virilité tout
simplement c'est à dire que les
relations à égalitaires hommes femmes
sont plus en poupe du côté des
démocrates que du côté des conservateurs
républicains donc c'est tout simplement
ça mais on parle des Américains il
faudrait aussi parler des états majeurs
des partis républicains comme démocrates
qui sont aujourd'hui dans un grand
embarras des deux côtés puisque le parti
républicain de son côté suite au
mitterme commencé à voir peut-être la
page Trump se tourner
les grands médias certains grands médias
américains commençaient à titre que
Trump était vraiment le plus grand loser
qui existait et là il y avait Rome De
Santis effectivement que sont plus sont
plus proches concurrents mais rendent de
santé ça pas encore l'assise l'assise de
Trump dans l'électorat puisque justement
il convoite de cet électorat raison pour
laquelle il ne peut pas se prononcer
trop viole contre Trump donc les
républicains sont assez embarrassés
puisqu'en partie il est toujours
favorable au candidat qui est
susceptible de gagner et pour les
démocrates ce n'est pas non plus une
excellente nouvelle si Trump était
inéligible ou sortez du jeu puisque ça
reste le meilleur adversaire face aux
candidats démocrates polarise en
reparlera un peu plus tard de la
réaction de ou de la non-réaction
d'ailleurs de Joe Biden et de des
conséquences politiques pour les pour
les démocrates j'ai une petite question
pour pour vous
Olivier python sur le le contrat enfin
le traitement médiatique c'est-à-dire le
contraste Trump il a voulu pendant toute
quoi cette journée ou c'est 48 heures
vraiment donner une image présidentielle
c'est ça c'était un avion à son à son
nom c'était un convoi le plus
présidentiel possible dans les rues de
New York c'est ça ce qu'il a voulu
renvoyer
oui tout à fait pour revenir sur le la
très intéressante intervention
précédente moi je vis dans un ce qu'on
appelle un trumconti c'est-à-dire je vis
au sud de Washington dans un endroit où
mes voisins très majoritairement votre
Donald Trump et pour répondre à votre
question il n'en ont effectivement
strictement rien à faire de ces
histoires de boucherie il considère
quand l'occurrence c'est un complot
qu'on cherche à la battre et qu'on
cherche à l'atteindre et rien ne pourra
changer cette donne et certainement pas
ce qui considère comme étant de toute
façon quelque chose de tout à fait
mineur faut pas oublier que l'électorat
féminin a majoritairement voté pour Joe
Biden et que c'est la grande faiblesse
de 2020 de Donald Trump l'électorat
féminin s'est reporté sur le candidat
démocrate et pour répondre à votre
question si vous voulez c'est toujours
Donald Trump a toujours joué la base
contre les élites républicaines en
particulier il a toujours essayé de
laisser entendre que de toute façon
l'espèce d'oligarchie républicaine ce
qu'il appelle lui-même les lentilles et
les bien-aîs qui sont du Nord de la Côte
Est en particulier de toute façon le
détestait il a toujours réussi à
mobiliser sa base pour contrer
l'état-major les stablishman comme on
pourrait dire républicain et il continue
là-dessus hier ce qui était très
intéressant lors de sa conférence de
presse tardive c'est qu'il a parlé à son
électorat comme le disait l'un de vos
intervenants il a fait de la politique
et il a parlé à son électorat il a tapé
là où ça fait mal il a recherché à
mettre à mettre en avant à remettre du
sel sur les plaies du clivage et donc il
va continuer tout le problème et en une
phrase tout le problème de Donald Trump
c'est qu'en 2016 Donald Trump qu'on aime
qu'on n'aime pas avait abordé un certain
nombre de sujets iconoclasses que la
société américaine n'abordait plus la
désindustrialisation le libre-échange
les les alliances militaires il le
faisait de manière brutale mais il
posait les sujets le problème
d'aujourd'hui c'est que Donald Trump ne
parle plus que de lui de lui-même et
tout tourne autour de son nombril et
c'est ça la véritable difficulté mais
André caspi
en ent pense que ce que vient de dire
Olivier python je me dis pourquoi le
parti républicain a autant de mal à se
débarrasser de Donald Trump on pourrait
se dire là il y a une occasion en or
elle est pas vraiment saisie oui
d'accord mais il y a aussi un électorat
qui comme on voulait expliquer suite
Donald Trump et pour répondre à la
question
sur le puritanisme bon allez-y je
voudrais simplement appeler personne
répond à mes questions ce soir mais
c'est pas grave c'est demander ça
d'animateur le Président il y a quelques
années de cela n'était pas non plus
d'impuritanisme absolu et je vous
rappelle également que Bill Clinton a
été traduit en épi de chemin précisément
parce que ça sa pratique sexuelle les 7
à désirer c'est ça un understickman il y
a eu un candidat démocrate qui s'appelle
Gary Hart si je me souviens bien qui lui
n'avait pas pu aller au bout de chance à
sa candidature à cause d'une affaire
d'adultère donc ça voilà ça ça met aussi
un donc je repose la question sur le
parce que j'ai bien compris qu'il y
avait un coeur ou un socle électoral pro
Trump chez les républicains mais est-ce
qu'il est majoritaire ce socle électoral
et pourquoi et et à quel point ça
explique le fait que les stablissements
tout le l'état-major des républicains ne
souhaite pas ou n'arrive pas à se
débarrasser non mais je pense que pour
l'instant il n'est pas encore vraiment
majoritaire mais plus Donald Trump est
attaqué et plus il y a de chances que ce
socle devienne majoritaire c'est-à-dire
qu'au fond il y a un rassemblement
derrière celui qui est considéré comme
une victime ou bien des médias ou bien
du Parti démocrate et en conséquence une
victime qui représente
la population ou une grande partie de la
population américaine c'est-à-dire de
ceux qui craignent que les démocrates
l'emportent et qu'à l'intérieur du parti
démocrate ce soit plutôt l'elgoche qui
l'emporte sur le reste de l'électorat et
puis il ne faut pas oublier on a aussi
une masse d'indépendance aux États-Unis
il n'y a pas que les électeurs
démocrates et les électeurs républicains
il y a aussi des indépendants et ces
indépendants voient ceux qui se passe si
pour une raison pour une autre la
procédure qui est engagée contre Donald
Trump
n'aboutit pas à ce moment-là il
apparaîtra encore plus comme une victime
et une victime on la soutient mais on
peut aussi dire que Donald Trump est
devenu un emploi le terme à loser ou une
machine à perdre les deux derniers
scrutins ils ont été perdus par les
républicains et il a sa part de
responsabilité il a clairement sa part
de responsabilité mais je pense que la
raison pour laquelle c'est très
difficile pour les stabilisations de
républicain de se débarrasser Donald
Trump c'est effectivement sa base et sa
base qui a alors je me prononcerai pas à
majoritaire ou pas mais qui est très
importante et on le voit à la réaction
du gouverneur de Floride qui avait tenté
de se distancier de Donald Trump De
Santis et qui est son principal on va
dire
potentiel enfin voilà de faire du
tramplisme sans Trump et on a vu sa
réaction face à la mise en examen c'est
qui s'est recentré qui s'est rapproché
Donald Trump en dénonçant
l'instrumentalisation du port judiciaire
donc on voit bien que même c'est rivaux
qui voulait s'éloigner de lui sont
contraints par la procédure de faire
bloc avec lui de faire bloc avec la base
pour dénoncer l'instrumentalisation du
pouvoir judiciaire comment vous
l'analysez ça va ils achètent il y a
aussi une question de relève
générationnel au sein du parti
républicain citron et parvenu la
première fois à se hisser à ses
fonctions c'est aussi parce que il y
avait un problème de relève
générationnel le fait qu'un homme des
médias qui n'avaient aucune expérience
en politique puisse prendre le parti
nous dit quand même quelque chose de
l'état du parti républicain et de la
question du leadership en son sein donc
il y a il y a une vraie question de
cette relève et Donald Trump a réussi à
imposer quelque chose que c'est que les
autres élites ont du mal à faire c'est
un style populaire il parle un langage
que les gens comprennent l'Américain
moyen comprend alors autant ça irrite
les élites éduquer des grands urbain
mais il est compris des autres de des
Américains moyens faut pas oublier que
la vague populiste qui a traversé
l'Europe a aussi concerné les États-Unis
et procéder notamment de la critique
d'élite trop éloignée de des réalités du
terrain et Trump a su répondre à cette
demande donc ce n'est pas seulement un
accident de parcours c'est quelqu'un qui
a su répondre à une demande Olivier
python comment Fox News qui soutenait
Trump avant de plus ou moins lâcher
comment faut illustrer ce dossier est-ce
qu'elle est à fond derrière Donald Trump
sur ce dossier là oui c'est à dire que
ce qui est intéressant est-ce que vous
avez dit vous avez l'ensemble de
l'établissement américain républicain
pardon qui qui avait réussi non seul qui
déteste Donald Trump depuis le début on
pense à gior du bouchon pense à mitfomie
on pense à lift Channel et Fox News qui
très récemment a fini par se démarquer
Donald Trump sont d'une seule voix
condamne ce qu'ils appellent en fait une
chasse aux sorcières et et
un procès politique donc ce que l'un des
exploits qu'a réussi malgré lui
mais c'était pas le but Alvin braque
c'est de ressouder l'ensemble du camp
républicain derrière Donald Trump y
compris les gens qui ne le supportent
pas il a bondit dans les sondages il est
passé de 41 à plus de 53 ou 54% les
sondages dans le yugov le dernier
sondage qui est sorti alors que Run De
Santis est passé sous la barre des 40%
de d'intention de vote donc si vous
voulez on a et 80%
selon sondage 79% exactement des sondés
républicains déclarent souvenir Donald
Trump donc en fait on comprend bien que
la l'objectif Donald Trump et de
retourner à son avantage le le
l'incultation qui a été fait il joue
donc effectivement la carte politique et
il oblige c'est surtout ça l'information
sans doute la plus importante il oblige
l'ensemble de ces rivaux l'ensemble de
les stablissement l'ensemble de la
techno structure républicaine à se
ranger derrière lui et donc il apparaît
de plus en plus comme l'incontournable
prétendant à la primaire même si il peut
se passer encore beaucoup de temps d'ici
au mois de janvier André casse-pied ce
qui illustre particulièrement cette
évolution c'est l'attitude de Mike pence
my penns ancien vice-président c'était
l'ancien vice-président entre pence et
Trump il y a eu une affaire très
importante ils se sont fâchés à la suite
du 6 janvier précisément c'est à dire
que Mike pence présidait au des votes
électoraux et
Trump souhaitait que Mike pence arrête
my pen ça n'a pas fait et cette fois-ci
Mike pence vient au secours de Donald
Trump c'est à dire qu'au fond lui Mike
pence qui a aussi des ambitions
présidentielles il est moins bien placé
que Trump mais Mike pence aussi veut
montrer que il est solidaire du
Président lorsque le président est
attaqué par les démocrates c'est-à-dire
qu'au fond tout cela montre bien que à
l'intérieur du monde politique américain
il y a une très profonde fracture c'est
à dire que il est impensable si vous
voulez que les républicains puissent
avoir quelques sympathies pour les
démocrates et les démocrates quelques
sympathie pour les républicains non
c'est-à-dire que c'est toute la société
américaine qui est profondément fracturé
en deux camps et c'est de cela bien
entendu que Donald Trump profite alors
vous avez commencé à nous parler de Joe
Biden et du camp démocrate on va y que
le dernier chapitre de ce débat et je
vous propose d'entendre la réaction de
la porte-parole de la Maison Blanche sur
cette inculpation de Donald Trump
ce n'est pas un sujet qui lui tient à
cœur Joe Biden va se concentrer sur
d'autres choses comme s'assurer que nous
continuons à baisser les prix pour le
peuple américain bien sûr cette affaire
est diffusée quotidiennement sur de
nombreuses chaînes pendant des heures et
des heures donc évidemment il suivra une
partie de l'actualité quand il aura un
moment pour se tenir au courant mais ce
n'est pas une priorité pour lui
dire
vous permet de terminer un peu et de
continuer la démonstration que vous
aviez amorcée tout à l'heure pourquoi il
est gêné aux entournures Joe Biden parce
que Trump serait son meilleur adversaire
Joe Biden a fait un excellent score en
terme de vote populaire quand il est
affronté Trump parce que Trump est très
clivant donc il y a aussi une réaction
très forte antitrump chez chez les
démocrates et aussi chez une partie des
indépendants donc c'était son meilleur
adversaire aujourd'hui Joe by dance
soude le camp démocrate d'une certaine
façon on peut dire ça
il suscite en tout cas il suscite des
réactions si si on considère les le
nombre de voix qu'à récolté Joe Biden il
a eu 82 millions de voix
[Musique]
aux dernières élections Trump on avait
eu 65 millions donc c'était vraiment
donc c'était c'était vraiment largement
au dessus donc il a réussi à fédérer Joe
Biden est un président vieillissant on
entend aujourd'hui quand même des
géronsologues venir sur les ondes
américaines pour défendre la kabyle en
expliquant que le vieillissement chez
l'homme peut s'exprimer différentes
manières parfois les capacités
cognitives restent intactes on touche le
fond en termes de défense de défense
politique donc Joe Biden n'a pas préparé
de succession il peut encore le faire
mais je pense qu'il doit aussi réfléchir
à ça et quelque part je pense qu'il
souhaiterait que Trump soit face à
l'huissier ici il était désigné par son
parti pour pour se représentera 82 ans
en novembre 2024 c'est à dire au moment
du scrutin sur ce point il y a un autre
argument qui peut expliquer
effectivement le la gêne de Biden ou du
moins la distance qu'il prend et c'est
tout à fait compréhensible c'est que les
élus démocrates n'ont aucun intérêt à
commenter l'affaire puisque précisément
l'argument de Trump et de parler de
politisation et d'instrumentalisation
ils ont tout intérêt à effectivement à
mettre de la distance et dire nous
laissons les institutions travailler et
nous ne nous mêlons pas de cela et
quelque part c'est une bonne chose parce
que avoir des élus démocrates qui
prendrai position sur la mise en examen
effectivement renforcerait les arguments
de Donald Trump sur
l'instrumentalisation du mois judiciaire
pourquoi vous avez quand je disais le
une candidature Trump souderait le camp
démocrate vous n'êtes pas convaincu
pourquoi bah parce que le camp démocrate
ne s'est pas très bien quelle candidat
soutenir alors il est évident que
officiellement si c'est Joe byden qui se
présente les démocrates le soutien on ne
peut pas ne pas soutenir le président
sortant mais je ne pense pas que ce soit
avec enthousiasme c'est à dire qu'au
fond les démocrates aimeraient bien
qu'il y ait un autre candidat mais un
candidat qui qui puisse faire front et
pour l'instant il y en a pas il y en a
pas parce que Joe Biden bloque
littéralement la situation il dit je
n'ai pas encore décidé tout à fait
d'être président ou candidat mais
vraisemblablement je le saurai donc si
vous voulez il y a une sorte de
d'obscurité sur ces intentions et cela
gêne énormément les beaucoup d'électeurs
démocrates je suis certain que une
majorité des électeurs démocrates
souhaiteraient un autre candidat que Joe
Biden je rappelle que vous avez écrit
une biographie de kamalaharis la
vice-présidente elle fait elle a pas
vraiment émergé pendant pendant ces deux
premières années de mandat elle n'offre
pas une alternative crédible à une
quantité une candidature pardon de Joe
Biden
moi je la défends toujours si vous
voulez que le problème de kamalari c'est
très très compliqué depuis le départ
parce que si jamais on fait trop on va
la on va la l'accuser d'être une
intrigante une une ambitieuse qui va
absolument prendre la place du patron et
si elle en fait pas si elle n'en fait
pas assez on va l'accuser d'être un peu
potiche Fallout etc donc elle réussit
pour l'instant à mener ce sabarque
plutôt bien et elle est en réserve
effectivement puisqu'il est hors de
question pour elle de se présenter
contre Joe Biden concernant le match
probable possible en tout cas le match
retour entre Joe Biden et Donald Trump
il faut comprendre que pas loin de 80%
des Américains ne le souhaitent pas ils
souhaitent un changement et que
deuxièmement ce qui a fait l'élection de
Joe Biden en 2020 c'est surtout le fait
d'avoir arraché à Donald Trump une
partie non négligeable du vote blanc
populaire de la de ce qu'on appelle la
ceinture rouillée c'est-à-dire des états
du Wisconsin de Pennsylvanie et du
Michigan
est-ce que la situation il faudra aussi
parler à ce moment-là la situation
économique et ce que la situation
économique permettra de Joe Biden de
conserver ce petit électorat blanc
d'ouvriers d'employés de ce qu'on
appelle rapidement l'école bleue rien
n'est moins sûr et donc on verra à ce
moment-là ce qui peut se passer merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je rappelle André caspi que
vous chronique américaine sont publiés
aux éditions de l'Observatoire et puis
le vieux python votre livre kamalaharis
la pionnière de l'Amérique publié chez
plomb merci encore une fois aux uns et
aux autres